we have some really great discussion
happening on the david pakman show
subreddit i
and some not so good which i will point
to today you can find the subreddit at
davidpakman.com
reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t here's a post
i spotted this morning and this is
really sad
a user illustrious worth writes my
father is a right-wing conservative and
he's
too deep into magaland he's even trying
to drag me into it
what can i do to get him out i should
probably explain further they write
the majority of my family members are
democrats and my father is pretty much
the only republican in the family
he's been making me listen to
conservative radio for the past few
months so he can as he puts it give you
a different perspective he does listen
to me in my opinions from time to time
but he's the dominant one when it comes
to political issues
i'm going to try to make him watch an
episode of dave's radio show i think
that means me
or at least listen but i understand
that he may not change his view
instantly
this is a really tough thing and this is
affecting a lot of families
and in terms of advice and deprogramming
people as i've said before
the i don't know what the wholesale
strategy is for deprogramming nearly 75
million trumpists i don't know what that
is
they seem really strongly programmed
it's resistant
to change that programming but the best
way is
if you have the time individual
relationships over longer periods of
time it's a lot of work but it's
starting to talk to your dad about how
did he come to the conclusions that he
came to
how does he determine that something is
true and something they should believe
what does it mean to them that they
believe that's how the world is or
what would it mean to them if the
reality was different than that which
they believe this can be a big
revelation to a lot of people where they
say oh
there's a reason why i'm so attached to
this belief
because if i didn't believe it to be
true it would change my perspective of
this that the other thing
this is really really tough but to be
honest if you're willing to put in the
work the best way the the
the retail strategy of
building a relationship with someone and
talking to them over months and months
and examining where their beliefs come
from and where their news comes from
it's one of the only ways that you can
really change people's minds but it is a
hell of a lot of work i don't envy
uh that viewer whatsoever now here's
another one this
i don't like this at all i've said
before on the show tell me why i'm wrong
about the things i actually say
tell me where i'm wrong about the things
i actually believe but one of the things
i i am disgusted by the most is people
who get mad at me about things i didn't
say
and someone posted a reddit thread about
my view on masks
that is not based in anything i've
actually said and the user writes
why david pakman doesn't like wearing a
mask every time
mr pac-maniac talks about how he just
follows the cdc guidelines and how he
doesn't wear it outside gives the
impression he's disgusted with wearing
it
no no i've never expressed that and in
fact all along i've expressed
let's do what the cdc is saying i'm not
an anti-master
the viewer goes on to say i get the
impression he doesn't fully understand
that wearing a mask can also protect you
against catching cold cough
etc from someone else as well as the
seasonal
influenza in the winter but he doesn't
even hint at that being a useful habit
to adopt for u.s society
when seasonal influenza comes this is
the opposite of what i've said first of
all
when it comes to outdoor masking people
aren't catching the virus outside
people aren't catching the flu outside
people aren't catching colds outside
people aren't catching cough outside and
i've actually said
it would be a really interesting way to
deal with flu
if during flu season indoors
where people actually transmit flu
grocery stores or whoever said please
wear a mask
or if people just decided hey you know
what the experience of covid is going to
tell me during flu season
i'm going to choose to wear a mask
indoors this person is criticizing me
for a belief that is the opposite of my
belief
they go on to say why is it that these
types of entitled people such as
david in the u.s always feel their
freedom is being violated when they're
asked to do something for someone else
seems they just don't want others
telling them what to do you people in
the u.s are way behind
you you it's almost like you're
attacking me if as if i were rand paul
i have never made the freedom and
liberty argument about masks what i've
said all along is i've seen no evidence
that this is being transmitted outdoors
but i'll wear it when the cdc says wear
it outdoors when the cdc said you don't
have to wear it outdoors i said that
makes sense to me
i will follow the cdc guidelines and no
longer wear the mask outdoors it's not
about freedom
i've always said i'm part of the team i
will do what needs to be done
if this is what we're doing right now to
show that we are participating in the
effort to defeat
the virus then i'm absolutely going to
go ahead and do it guys criticize me for
things i've said
not for things i haven't said okay join
the discussion
at davidpakman.com reddit
that's r-e-d-d-i-t one of our sponsors
is privacy.com they're giving you five
dollars when you sign up for their
completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them
anytime you want so when you do this it
means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at
privacy.com slash pacman